big update by the way coming in that
Fabiano Karana has made a blunder just
when we left it w we thought it was in
Cruz whoo wo wo wo what happened there
but the KN on C6 is w we would we saw we
left it at F5 and we were we were all
Applause and something went grossly
wrong oh my God look at Fabby he react
oh yeah you just saw his head in his
hands as Queen G4 rocked his world queen
G4 forces his King into a uh double
attack Queen F4 check he's dropped his
rook and oh no uh it's now a draw easy
draw easy easy easy draw and it felt
like he did everything right out of the
opening gets a winning position but then
somewhere let's go of that very big
advantage and that's it we've got
handshakes it's game over Wesley so
survives